fox news has called virginia's
governor's race for republican candidate
glenn yonkin go to foxnews.com for the
latest i'm greg gutfeld i'm martha
mccallum i'm brett bear and this is the
fox news rundown
wednesday november 3rd 2021 alisa brady
a persistent supply chain backlog could
lead to a not so happy holiday season
it's gonna be a problem and it's gonna
start hitting it's already hit but
certainly november or december are going
to be tough months for a lot of
purchases on you name it i'm chris
foster supreme court takes up challenges
to abortion cases in texas and soon
mississippi the court is going to have
to decide whether it wants to give
states
some more flexibility it could even
decide to simply
get rid of roe v wade
and i'm joe koncha i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
about 40 of shipping containers entering
the u.s pass through two california
ports which continue to have a backlog
despite president biden's push for more
of the supply chain to run 24 7. supply
chains is something that most of our
citizens never think twice about
until something goes wrong he brought
the issue with him to europe telling
other g20 leaders that ending the
pandemic is what's needed to end the
disruptions a simultaneous pitch for
vaccinations and infrastructure
investments to help prevent a future
backlog
florida has been investing in its ports
since i became governor in 2019 we've
allocated almost a billion dollars to
over 70 florida seaport projects
governor ron desantis says they have the
capacity to help alleviate log jams
though the biden administration has also
pointed to an outdated supply chain
infrastructure among shippers and
retailers not able to handle surging
demand california's twin ports of la and
long beach plan to start fining shipping
companies later this month for
containers waiting to be unloaded for
too long a three-day limit if they're
supposed to move by rail nine days if
scheduled for trucking you know if i was
going to point at one thing where there
could be some help i think we're all
looking at and even here in florida
you know there is still a shortage of
truck drivers out there michael rubin is
president and ceo of the florida ports
council that is going to be an area of
weakness regardless of where you go
and i think that's one area where
certainly if we were to do something on
a federal level i know there's some
regulations they could lift at least
you know nobody there's issues with
allowing 18 plus year olds to to drive
but you know some of them would be quite
capable and and why not at this time
looking to get
uh more of those individuals on the
roads because they that truck driver
will help not only with you you know
people are learning about chassis and
those things as well so you need
somebody to move those as well so i
think if you're looking for
you know a problem that is nationwide it
could could be something that could be
done right now to help with some
alleviation would be probably you know
trying to get more truck drivers on the
road i wanted to dig in a little deeper
on that because at least anecdotally
some truckers
dispute reports of an actual trucker
shortage and they say it is just an
issue of not getting chassis quickly
enough to move goods out of warehouses
so more containers can be unloaded from
ships you know kind of a snowball effect
so how does that process how does that
process work in florida is it different
in florida than it is when a trucker
drives in to pick up a load in a
california port
certainly over on the west coast where
there are you know an inordinate amount
of of containers you have
you know chassis pools and chassis
companies and the like that that own
some of those
that that deal with that issue but it
still
you know we have a little bit out of
florida it's not as bad certainly are
some of our drainage uh you know the
distance from our port to
wherever the heck they're dropping that
chassis off may not be as significant
uh so they do have some of that issue in
california where they're trying to get
that chassis returned to the chassis
pool operator we don't have as much
chassis pool operators as they do over
there and i you know i couldn't i
certainly couldn't speak to the specific
on the chassis over there but you do
need somebody
uh to move that chassis from where it's
at you know whether it's empty or not
whether it has an empty container on it
or not
back to the port proper to uh
try to get that there so i'm sure
you know while there may
be truckers waiting on that chassis i
think that's probably true over there
somebody's got to move that chassis back
we should probably clarify when we say
chassis we're talking about the the part
of the truck that the
driver is driving right that attaches
you know that they would put the
container on because i always had this
vision in my mind anyway which turns out
to be the wrong vision i guess
of um you know a driver sort of driving
the cab up to the port to have it loaded
up and be and take stuff away and that
isn't they're kind of what
a lot of them are independent
contractors and they're showing up in
their own car and they're picking up a
chassis to get a load onto it right it
runs the gamut we have independent
truckers we have trucking companies uh
just depends on how it's moving but that
chassis is kind of that back bed that
you might see you know the cab so you
could have a trucker driving his own cab
and then you need to hook to the chassis
and then you need to drop the container
on that chassis it's kind of three parts
really so
exactly there's three parts well set and
and so
you know they all three kind of fit into
this mix at some point so there's plenty
of those containers you know they may be
empty which is another story uh
trying to get those empties out of the
way too
but it's it's
you know there are issues with the
chassis itself in some cases and they
may
probably are not owned by the truck
driver they may not be owned by the
trucking company uh they may be owned by
an independent entity that is a chassis
facility chassis
pool owner
so it's
there's a number of players in this
craziness
and it tends to not be easy at some
point if everybody's not working
together on it i know that florida
governor ron desantis has called your
ports you know a model for the country
talked about the investments that have
been made over the past few years
and he has highlighted the fact that
florida has gotten some more shipping
business
recently um for instance jaxport
hadn't had a european container ship in
years and then had one in october
another big one came from india into
port everglades is that happening
because there's such a backlog at other
ports especially california or is that
because sort of the word is out that
florida made these investments and now
you can handle
bigger containers there
i would say both uh you know certainly
when i've said this before when people
looked at florida years ago and you know
we're primarily talking about an
east-west trade route in asia anyway but
that's those trade routes have really
started shifting and really shifted with
the opening of the panama canal several
years ago so
we've been investing and trying to make
sure everybody knew that florida was a
place that you could come to conduct
that business we weren't the end of the
road we in fact could be the beginning
of the road for especially for vessels
coming out of the panama canal and we
started getting more vessels from the
suez including what you just talked
about at jacksonville
uh so we we've made those investments i
think
the highlight of the problems with the
supply chain especially over and between
asia and california which
you know has been been a supply chain
route for years but it's reached its
capacity
and this has been an opportunity for us
to tell those
uh shipping lines and carriers and
others involved in it you know
especially if you're trying to shift
that cargo to the east coast united
states
uh we had the capacity to deal with
a lot of those vessels now
we've got the post panamax cranes
uh miami has dredged is this dredge was
one of the i think maybe the second
port on the east coast the united states
that dredged to 50 feet
jacksonville be at that depth soon and
everglades is is making that depth as
well but still jacksonville and
everglades as you mentioned can take
those those larger vessels sometimes
they can't be fully loaded when they go
into those two ports but
they can handle those vessels they have
the cranes that can reach across
and pull those containers off
so we've made a lot of investments to
improve the ability and capacity of our
ports to
to deal with those larger container
vessels meanwhile we've got some pretty
busy ports in the gulf coast as well you
know they primarily deal with the a
little bit of the smaller vessels out
there but
they've been growing rapidly
in the movement of goods as well
as someone who deals with ports you know
for a living really i mean did you see
any of this coming is this an issue
that's been bubbling up for
a while um you know is it really just uh
is it mainly driven by post-pandemic
issues or recovery recovering from the
pandemic issues the white house has
talked about you know just more consumer
demand we're just you know buying more
stuff and more stuff is being shipped
here um did you foresee any of this
uh it's been a discussion if you look at
some of the the house commerce and a
little bit over in the senate as well
the transportation infrastructure
committee they've talked about freight
for a bit
uh just wasn't one of those issues that
they gave a lot of credence to
but but we haven't invested properly in
this country's freight infrastructure
for a while and
you know i look at the
supply chain
task force set up by
the the president's administration and
i'm glad he's doing that
but again it's focused on
you know i understand the focus on the
look there's other issues with respect
to that including where we're purchasing
things like chips and other stuff from
but if you're talking supply chain and
you you don't have seaports and and
truckers and everybody else involved in
that discussion and you're not really
focused on supply chain you're focused
on manufacturing products so
it doesn't get
the attention that it deserved and and
we knew
a lot of us knew that uh you know we've
been trying to get more money to it um
you know both presidents have put some
money into it yet president trump puts
some more money into it certainly
you know i'm hopeful that president
biden will put some more money into it
but it's been an issue for a while
um and i think it's just
you know covent highlighted it a little
bit because it pressed it but it's not
going away
well one last thing and it may be the
toughest question of all um are you and
your family personally worried about you
getting or sending holiday gifts in time
my wife uh a very smart woman although
she married me had already done a number
of the holiday shopping we had so she
got it out of the way i guess that's
what she gets for being married for so
long to a supply chain nerd so yeah
she's out there but i you know you're
seeing it and you're gonna see it in
groceries uh you're gonna see it for you
know just normal things you you're used
to buying uh
you know certainly anybody that's done
amazon shopping and remembers the days
of one to two days shopping off amazon
is now getting a stark reality on on
that kind of stuff so it it's gonna be a
problem and it's gonna
start hitting it's already hitting but
certainly november and december are
going to be tough months for a lot of
purchases on on you name it
michael rubin president ceo of the
florida ports council
um good luck as the as the supply crunch
continues i guess and thank you very
much for spending some time with us
well thank you for giving me the
opportunity i appreciate it thank you
[Music]
this is joe koncha with your fox news
commentary coming up
the supreme court on tuesday heard
arguments about the law in texas
allowing civil lawsuits against anyone
helping a woman get an abortion justices
heard two challenges one from the biden
administration another from abortion
providers in texas and they aren't for
now considering the constitutionality of
the law this is just about the right to
challenge it and try to stop texas
judges and court clerks from hearing
those abortion lawsuits justice elena
kagan says about the law using private
citizens to do the enforcement not the
state of texas through a criminal
statute that would go against federal
abortion rights the fact that after
all these many years
some geniuses came up with a way
to evade the commands
of that decision as well
as the command that the broader even the
even broader principle that states are
not to nullify federal constitutional
rights she says she doesn't understand
the legal argument for it many of the
justices seemed exasperated by what
was done here jonathan turley is a fox
news contributor a constitutional law
expert and a professor at george
washington university in some ways the
law itself suffered from overkill not
only did
they make this a private enforcement
mechanism which made it difficult to
enjoy
but they also imposed some pretty
draconian
provisions you know they allowed for
pro-life litigants to re to recoup their
attorney's fees but barred it for the
other side they allowed people to file
in any district in texas instead of the
one that they reside in there are a lot
of provisions like that that raise the
ire of even conservatives on the court
asking why
why did you need to go this far
so i think that they may have lost
roberts and kavanaugh on the merits
uh but it does come down to this very
difficult question on the other side
there are legitimate questions about
what the court is being asked to do here
it is not very common for a court to
tell
state clerks don't even allow a case to
be filed don't allow it to even be heard
don't allow people to state their case
that's a pretty extreme measure and it's
not clear yet how the court is going to
deal with that could it be a case where
look we've got to have a test case and
have and have one of these lawsuits be
seen through from start to finish and
then we can
discuss it
yeah some of the justices were saying
look that you know you're complaining
that this creates a chilling effect
because it takes a while to get it to us
by the usual means and justices said
well you know there's lots of laws like
that they restrict the first amendment
or gun rights
and you know we don't intervene until
clerks don't allow these cases to be
filed
so those are very good arguments the
court could try something novel they
could just refuse to impose the
injunction
but accept the case for review on the
merits uh now this was essentially an
acceptance of the court before
uh judgment so basically they were
allowing argument to see if they wanted
to take the case they could do that
without imposing an injunction or come
up with some more novel construction
it does seem to me like there's a
majority on the court
that is inclined to view the statute
unconstitutional in part or in whole
just judging from the statements of
chief justice roberts and justice
kavanaugh what is also interesting is
that this is really not the major
abortion case that case is the dobbs
case and it's not out of texas it's out
of mississippi
and that is supposed to be argued in a
matter of weeks
so this is all throwing the docket into
a bit of disarray
yeah i mean it's possible that if the
texas law is allowed to stand pending
challenges the whole thing could be
rendered mood anyway if the abortion
ruling comes down before the texas
ruling has ever stopped now explain
uh what the mississippi case is and why
that's clearly
more potentially more of a game changer
for abortion
well the dobbs case has been a great
concern for good reason for
pro-choice advocates first of all many
cases involving abortion have
multiple issues that give
these types of off-ramps for the court
you know if they do deadlock or they
can't resolve an issue they often
find a way to send the case back down or
limit the basis of the decision
dobbs is
direct
and unavoidable it simply asks whether
states
can enact these types of limitations or
prohibitions during what's called the
pre-viability stage now texas
is incredibly
early in that stage they're at six weeks
which is uh really the earliest of the
state laws that we've seen come before
the courts
mississippi allows twice that but it's
still
or basically a little over twice that
but it it still uh
is
banning abortions in that pre-so-called
pre-viability stage
so the court is going to have to decide
whether it wants to give states
some more flexibility it could even
decide to simply
get rid of roe v wade and casey the case
that followed it
most of us would be surprised if they
had an outright reversal of roe
it wouldn't sit well with figures like
roberts who's a bit of an incrementalist
he he gets sticker shock on opinions
kavanaugh
is very much like roberts and that was
always the irony you know trump when he
appointed kavanaugh said that he didn't
want another mistake like roberts which
was i think unfair to roberts but
uh
that was the sort of premise that he
wanted a quote real conservative and at
the time i wrote that that was a rather
curious choice because kavanaugh
is is
very similar to roberts even when he was
nominated and he's turned out to be that
on the court he tends to be more of an
institutionalist and incrementalist much
like roberts so what might they do what
might the off-ramp be for dobbs
i don't think there is an off ramp uh it
has a single question
uh usually we have a multiplicity of
questions before the cohort uh this does
not have an easy procedural question
that they can turn to uh they're going
to have to address it straight up
and that means that this newly
constituted majority which includes
justice barrett
is going to have to rule on the
continued viability of
roe and casey now barrett when she was a
law professor
wrote extensively on roe and she
questioned the basis of roe
and she had some very profound and
interesting ideas
but she was legitimately viewed as
someone who was not
enthusiastic about roe so we're going to
see if that has changed now that she is
sitting in one of nine chairs
is it necessarily very ominous for
people who are pro-choice and
necessarily or necessarily
cause to celebrate for uh people who are
anti-abortion that they even took this
case in the first place that obviously
if they if they took it up
there's
other courts may not have taken in the
past uh a case this cut and dry they do
they does it signal that they want to
make a decision on it
i i think it does i think it is ominous
there's two cases
that
seem
clearly designed for this newly
constituted
conservative majority one of them is a
case to be argued
the braun case that case seems to have
been selected for the sole purpose of
reversing the second circuit
and reaffirming gun rights
this is also that type of case the
single question presented in dobbs
really has all the makings of a case
selected by the conservative side of the
court what do you think of roe
even some legal experts who are
pro-choice have said look it's just not
a good law
well row itself really doesn't exist
anymore uh you know roe
was built around blackman's view of the
trimester type of uh methodology that we
would break the periods into three
trimesters and then the state's
authority would grow with time that was
largely tossed out in casey that is
casey
years later was a decision of the court
that said we don't want that
methodology anymore instead they adopted
the undue burden test that you're not
allowed to impose an undue burden on
abortions but of course that standard
itself is quite ambiguous what
constitutes an undue
burden so the question for the court
this term is
uh
i as a threshold matter do they still
believe that this is a constitutional
right uh or something that should be
left to the states most people expect
that they will continue to recognize it
as a constitutional right and then the
second question is do we still believe
that states should have a limited role
early on in
pregnancies
in imposing limits or
outright prohibitions after a period of
time
that's the area that should worry
pro-choice
advocates
this does have the makings of a
potential significant
uh rollback on casey and when might that
happen
well this isn't going to be heard until
december so we're talking many weeks
away before we have any type of uh
decision so
it's not going to be something that's uh
right away but it will occur
we will get the decision before the
midterm elections and so
uh you know we we already have
great division in the country over the
supreme court and calls for it to be
packed if the supreme court were to come
out with a very strong gun rights
decision uh in braun come out with a
pro-life type of decision in
dobbs i i that that that
politicalization of the court is likely
to be magnified for the midterms and a
lot of republicans not that they aren't
all necessarily anti-abortion but there
could be you know a bit of a the dog
catching the car what do i do with it
now because for so many years
republicans have run
on we're going to stop abortion
yeah i expect that abortion will and the
supreme court will continue central in
our politics
i keep in mind that even if the court
were to take the unlikely step of just
getting rid of roe and casey
that would just simply return the issue
back to the states most states would
still be
pro-choice
uh there would be likely 12 to 15 states
where uh the battleground would shift to
uh to the states
but uh this this
any any
type of decision like that would simply
affirm it as a state issue not uh to ban
abortions as a decision of the supreme
court jonathan turley is a fox news
contributor law professor at george
washington university a constitutional
law expert that's why we bring them on
from time to time for these
conversations jonathan let's talk to you
again
thank you very
[Music]
much did you hear the news now you can
with instant updates from fox news for
amazon alexa just say alexa play news
from fox in fox news it's the latest
when you need it on demand from fox news
and amazon alexa subscribe to this
podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com it's time for your
fox news commentary
joe koncha
what's on your mind president biden fell
asleep at a climate change conference in
glasgow for the world to witness
and it's a fitting symbolism for this
absentee president an absentee president
on the u.s southern border a crisis he
refuses to see up close by visiting said
border a president asleep at the wheel
on afghanistan where u.s service members
died and hundreds of americans are still
trapped behind enemy lines a president
only adding to inflation fears by
pushing trillions more in new spending a
president who doesn't address rising
violent crime in american cities and a
president who won't go to america's
ports where hundreds of cargo ships are
stuck with no resolution to the supply
chain crisis in sight here's two numbers
to chew on nbc news poll 71
more than seven and ten of americans say
this country is on the wrong track just
36 percent a smidge over one-third of
democrats mind you say mr biden is the
best choice for the party to be its
nominee in 2024. joe biden he got some
shut eye in scotland making donald
trump's nickname for him sleepy joe
perhaps his most accurate yet i'm joe
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown rundown stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman from south
carolina brings you a one-of-a-kind
podcast subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
[Music]